euh oui il y avait eu 17 mains courantes
comme vous le disiez aussi 112 pour
défaut d'abreuvement c'estàdire qu'il ne
leur donnait pas à boire aux bêtes donc
l'accumulation ça fait en tout 130
plaintes l'accumulation a fait que le
procureur avait requis une peine plus
lourde et franchement il s'en sort bien
vu l'état des animaux il a jamais eu
preuve il y a jamais eu de preuve
tangible et moi je me demande quand même
mais ce n'est que mon avis si c'est pas
parce que il avait cette notoriété qui P
c'est la thèse de son avocat ou thèse
aussi parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
jalousie dans par bon voilà je voudrais
pasimag
qu' oui mais il y a auune preuve
tangible c'est surtout que le enfin si
on reprend les choses différemment le
secteur de l'agriculture aujourd'hui
c'est quand même quelque chose qui a
beaucoup de problèmes et si on reprend
les choses différemment je pense que il
y a beaucoup de demande en quantité pas
en qualité du coup les agriculteurs ils
doivent faire en masse et
malheureusement ils se retrouvent parce
qu'ils gagnent très peu à mettre au
détriment la la santé des animaux et
certainement qu'il y a beaucoup
d'agriculteurs pour qui c'est le cas et
c'est que lui a été mis ene visibilité
avec la avec l'amour est dans le prê
donc du coup il a été il mon avis c'est
ça il y a eu de la jalousie puis elle a
raison il y a une vraie urgence pour les
agriculteurs qui souffrent je vous le
dis voilà et c'est pour ça que j'aime
bien aussi laamour et dans le prê parce
que ça met ça met quand même un coup de
projecteur sur eu justement laamour et
dans le prê c'était lundi soir il y
avait Julien éleveur de vach latièr dans
le dou lui il a invité deux prétendantes
à venir chez lui et quand il les
accueille il dit pas bonjour Il leur met
un petit coup de pression sur leurs
chaussures
regarde allez rentre
bon par contre et tu peux m'enlever les
godasses oui bien sûr j'allais te
demander salut comment vas-tu ça va et
toi super tu m'enlèves les godass s'il
te plaît non mais j'ai d la même chose
lu je me suis fait engueuler aussi
hein voilà donc Julien il met des coups
de pression déjà ces deux prétendants
dès qu'ils arrivent c'est voilà c'est
une une petite tanée mais c'est pas
qu'un mec qui met des coups de pression
Julien c'est aussi un grand romantique
un poète
regarde pas
un tu fais comme ça avec un mec
le pauvre il doêre sur sa fin non mais
t'inquiète pas ça il y a pas de
souci je peux
gér TR c'est une pour chacun non est
pour toi que je le coupe la queue oui un
petit
peu alors normalement en théorie doit y
avoir si Bell
boule un peu comme autour de la table
quoi donc là alors si boules 1 2 3 4 5 6
c'est
bon vous aez bienê vu à ce
dîner votre place si là à chaque fois je
parle pas tellement de lui mais je parle
des autres candidats c'est qu'à chaque
fois j' regne l'émission je me dis mais
on comprend pourquoi ils sont
célibataires ils sont super désagréables
avec leurs prétendants on l'impression
que parce qu'ils sont font l'émission
tout leur est dû les femmes ils arrivent
ils pensent qu'il y a une chose laquelle
je vais choisir sans s'occuper de savoir
est-ce que est-ce que vais être charmant
est-ce que je vais être agréable bien
les accueillir ils en ont rien à taper
franchement a juste dit d'enlever ses
chaussures parce qu'elles étaient
pleines
de Me vous dit enlève tes chaussures non
mais je marche pas dans la bouche juste
avant non mais même non mais pas tu je
dire si c'est propr chez lui ça me Cho
pas tuux dire je suis content de te voir
je suis tellement j'étais impatient de
te voir et ce tu dis pas t grolles moi
je trouve ça casse l'ambiance quand on
va chez des gens et il demande d'enlever
les chaussures c'est insupportable tu le
fais de toi-même voilà tu le fais parce
que tu ses la personne un pe gêné mais
quand verbalise moi et en plus moi la
vérité les gens quilè des chaussures
chez
moi du tout envie de boire en
chausette sans déconner c'est bonant
c'est hygiénique tu dors tu marches dans
les crach tu marches dans la merde tu
March partout RZ to ton bébé il marche
par terre si tuas un bébé en basage ça
[Rires]
va tu Mones tes chaussettes as honte de
tes chaussettes mais c'est
vachement il peut partir 8h sur les
cha est pas bien c'est comme ça
qui ferit l'amour est dans le Pr tu
feris toi tu as envie de le faireou
envie moi je pleure tout le temps sur
cette émission je me retrouve dans plein
de gens par exemple Julien a dit une
phrase mais qui m'a tué il a dit
j'aimerais être important pour quelqu'un
voilà mais ça me parle non mais c'est
vrai moi j'adore cette émion importante
pour moi
ou mais moi je trouve que c'est la
Meille toiine alors moi c'est une
émission que j'adorerais présenter ah
oui ça ah
ou ce serait ce serait ce serait pour
toi franchement c'est vrai elle serait
très bien dans Laam et toi tu le ferais
ouais moi j'aime bien les agriculteurs
non c'est vrai tu pourrais écrire un
agriculteur dire voilà et aller vivre
non je ferai pas la démarche parce que
mais tu pourraas aller vivre comme ça
dans ouais si je reste chez moi de temps
en
temps VI une matinée d'accord surtout
que faut faut être né là-bas pour
pouvoir supporter quelqu'un de la ville
c'est les gens de la ville qui viennent
il ils idéalisent un peu le monde
agricole et ce et quand ils arrivent il
faut seever à 5h c'est vie très du
Payson à 5h du matin pourer des bêtes et
cetera faut man fumer et cetera il y a
des odeurs des trucs c'est très moi je
je les félicite c'est très dur à faire
grand-père était paysan je sais ce que
c'est et franchement eux ils arrivent
ils sont c'est drôle mais c'est drôle 5
jours vous voulez de ma gueule ou
pas un peu la tête du mec il ve se fout
de la gueule de quel vous avez souvent
plusieurs mots qui arrivent en même
temps c'est problème des gens qui sont
très intelligents ça arrive trop vite et
du coup on a du mal vous arrive pas trop
sou on le mettre sur ce
comp ça vous arrive pas trop souvent ah
là là là là on va passer maintenant à
Jean-Paul sééalier dans les sones il a
choisi deux prétendantes Christelle et
Maria et l'étape obligatoire quand elles
arrivent à la ferme c'est de faire les
courses et là on parle pas de légumes
pack d'au et cetera c'est beaucoup plus
direct regardez non mais ils sont très
très chauds dans la mor dans le Pr
regard bon les préservatifs ils sont
dans quel rayon on est embêté là
finalement on va en chercher 24 des
préservatifs va faire chercher 24 ah bah
tuas vou 24 pour pour la nuit et
tuassumes
Garsin là à partir de là je me suis dit
mais j'ai rien à faire ici en
fait et ensuite alors notre Jean-Paul il
est allé faire un petit tour de tracteur
avec Christelle histoire de de papoter
un peu quoi et ça se voyait légèrement
en fait il il s'en foutait totalement en
fait de ce qu' lui raconter regarde tu
CIS que je recherche quoi si je voulais
un amant ça ferait longtemps que je
alors là on voit là on voit bien la
précocité du cols qui est plus en fleur
et l'autre il est voilà et moi moi c'est
pareil il est en stade comme ça du coup
est-ce que tu as envie de me connaître
ou
pas est-ce que tu as envie de me
connaître ou pas du
coup je vais te faire voir le
c'est
chaudud j'ai l'impression qu'il a pas
très envie d' s rattrapé après pas fou
ça pourrait être ton style Jean-Paul ou
pas ah Jean-Paul il est il est il est
coquin il est marrant ouais ouais ça
pourrait mais il s'est rattrapé après
toi Jean-Paul il t'urait kiffé pardon
non mais sans rigoler non non mais c'est
mon genre moi j'aime bien les bien
enrobés enfin j'ai l'impression que tu
aimes un peu tout toi c'est pas fauxi te
dire ça tuas une palette B j'ai plus le
temps d'être difficile non non non
franchement tu je te le dis à chaque
fois moi je vais te dire he si voilà on
av je voilà
non passé à de doigts quoi à leur retour
à la ferme ils se font un un petit
plaisir euh dans la dans la voiture sous
les yeux de l'autre prétendante qui leur
faisait à manger euh regardez c'est la
meuf la moins lucide du monde que vous
allez
voir mon SiGe il arrive à se
coucher
hop en position banquelle tu imagines
ils vont croire que allez tant
pis je suis pas jaloux il a encore pas
fait son
choix ah ouais et ouais et ouais ouais
quoi bah ouais bah c'est beau oui c'est
l'amour quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a non
c'est l'amour tu aais aé tu aimé qu'on
fasse ça alors ben dans une voiture j'ai
déjà donné ça ah ouais c'est vrai
oui il y a 30 ans il y a 30 ans alors
traction une traction
avant non mais c'était quoi c'était
avant guerre avant la guerre non c'était
y a super longtemps j'avais juste 20 ans
mais c'était dans un parking souterrain
c'était pas très romantique maisme qu
même
AC non c'est vra quoi dans une voiture
ouais à l'arrière ou à l'avant euh on
avait fait un peu comme ça là les ou
avec l'acteur connu là ouais avecur Conn
et ouais c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une parte celui-là même pas il a été à
l'hôtel c'est vraiment une par il été
dans un parking s terrain non mais s
c'est qu même quelqu'un sais qu'il y a
des y a des caméras dans les parkings
sterrains enfin à l'époque il y en avait
pas à l'époque il y avait des
diapau c'est que là c'est un autre
délire il y avait un cum quand
même allez on termine avec Clément il a
26 ans il a jamais eu de copine de sa
vie ça va 26 ans ça va ça passe euh il
est mignon euh voilà comme il c'est
mignon il a plein de prétendantes dont
une Ann lor qui a passé son temps à
faire un rire assez chelou regardez VO
tiens je t'ai ramené un petit cadeau
voilà tu pouras pas oublier que c'est le
mien pas trop intimidé un peu quand même
peu ouais j'ai pas l'habitude bah c'est
sûr que après je me sens prête tout ça
ouais j'imagine le truc classique le
compte de fée voilà
ouis après c'est vrai
c'est c'est des jolis cux aussi ouais
merci toi
aussiveau enfant il y a pas de
souci
moi j'ai fait ce que j'avais à faire on
est cohérent je trouve donc
ouais ça se passe bien non oui ça se
passe bien oui c'est
ça c'est comme
j'espérais il est parfait
elle est mign elle est mign elle aussi
attend elle elle a jamais eu d'histoire
d'amour non plus il sont h timide tout
les elle va aller à la ferme il l'
choisi donc elle troublé elle troublé
non non ils sont ils sont pas ils vont
bien ensemble trè bien franchement
franement euh si c'est c'est c'est un
mon délire oui mais j'ai rien dit moi
justement tu pas justement justement tu
J